[Music]
let's go to ashley in nyc what's up
ashley
hey doctor john great to talk to you you
too what's up
um so
i'm just going to jump right into it
jump right into it swan dive into it
so i am extremely protective of my
mother um she is on the autism spectrum
and
her way of processing the world makes
her very vulnerable okay
um so she has survived four abusive
husbands
actually i should say we've survived
because it really impacted my brother
and i too
um
but uh her last her fourth marriage her
last marriage ended pretty dramatically
back in december 2020
um we'd all kind of felt like we'd
reached the finish line of this
toxic relationship you know these toxic
relationship choices but
now she has announced that she's in love
again um after only a couple dates
and of course this guy shows
these same red flags as all the other
husbands
so i don't know
we've been through this so many times
and i don't know if any of us can go
through this cycle for a fifth time
so i guess my question is
how do i protect my mom from choosing
another
toxic husband
oh she's so lucky to have you as her
daughter um
how
i i'm gonna be 100 honest is that cool
yes you can't
there is literally
nothing you can do
and what i would suggest you do how old
are you
uh mid-40s okay
um i would suggest you look back
over the last 20 years
at all of the ways you've tried to
protect her and the talks and the
conversations and the texts and the mean
faces at the husbands and all those
things
and none of that has worked
and there's something defeatist and sad
and honest
about saying
i can't fix this
short of some clinical diagnostic that
gave you guardianship of your mother
because she was incapable of taking care
of herself and i don't think if she's
able to get married on
i don't think you'd you would qualify
for that
right yeah not yet
so ultimately here's a hard thing
i've had to do it every family member
every person with a family i know who's
interested in boundaries has had to do
this
is you have to there comes a moment when
that family member also becomes a person
it's because the person that you love
and is your family
but they're also a person who is hurting
you
right and at some point you have to
make sure that you're well
especially in a feudal situation like
this and so what i would do is tell your
mom
very specifically
i'm not i'm choosing to not go through
number five
you're an adult
you're allowed to make decisions on your
own
but every time you are hurt it hurts me
and i ca and choosing to not be hurt a
fifth time
and so if she chooses to
move away from you
and go towards this relationship that's
gonna hurt
but there's nothing you can do about it
because you've tried up four other times
right
right but i feel like i'm leaving her
alone in another abusive situation like
i've always been her support system like
kind of
you you've been the adult
and i feel like i'd be leaving her
completely in the wilderness all by
herself if i distance myself
what's the other option
i guess going through it again
does that make sense is that does that
help her
how have you how have you helped her the
other four times
um
i can be very honest very honest
um
husband number two and three i actually
i would say helped run them off in a way
um
counseled her through it you know helped
her recognize the toxicity you know
talked about her she hasn't recognized
anything how valuable she is she hasn't
heard that message recognize it for a
while yeah she'll see it and then she'll
break it off
my guess is she sees that you are more
engaged with her
right not
that she's got some toxic thought
patterns in relationship patterns that
she needs to do something different with
and i don't know if that's because of
her cognitive capacity i don't know if
that's because of childhood traumas or
both who knows why
but the reality is she hasn't learned
those messages and so this is going to
be really ugly what i'm about to say
the help that you have given her has
been
you've loved her
and you have loved her unconditionally
and you have continued to walk alongside
her
the lessons you've given her have not
worked
and that's what i'm saying
you're continuing to pour water into a
bucket with hole with a hole in it
and so here's what boundaries look like
the same as you probably do with your
kids which is
you will always have a place to stay
he will not be welcome
you will always um i'll always take care
of you but from this point forward
you're gonna come this way
i unless you decide uh are you married
no okay unless you decide your brother
decide well here we go again we're just
going to be in this and if so make peace
with that make don't fight that yeah
make peace with it yeah
i am my mother's ninja warrior and
that's just what i do
i i fight
i
help run off bad guys
right and then she attracts the next one
and then i run that guy
yeah
if that if you choose nice in the moment
there's a lot of resentment i think
attacked
that i've never told her because i don't
want to hurt her feelings but
is she unable to
why are you why are you protect her so
much
well
she sees the world
differently so she the way that she
processes the world she takes everything
very
literally she doesn't understand sarcasm
manipulation deceit you know these kind
of things and so
she is very easy to be lied to because
she'll believe anything that somebody
tells her
um and i think for whatever reason she
attracts men
who
will lie to her
and when she's in love logic goes out
the window
she doesn't see anything
but i think that if it were anybody else
who
who could kind of wake up and realize
the manipulation
and the lies
i would back off probably more but i
feel like unless i am there to
i would say almost interpret for her
what's happening in front of her and to
lay the foundation this is manipulation
what he said to you isn't true you're
worth more than that you realize that
you know whatever
if i'm not there to interpret the
situation for her
i feel like she would actually be in a
worse
position
than she's already found herself in so i
do see myself as a protector
um which i would
probably just keep doing if it didn't
impact
me in the process
so you know
you want both sides of the fence
you can't i do well i just don't want to
resent her for it
so i want to still help her you've got
to choose to not be to not be resentful
which means you got to carry yourself
right and so if you're choosing to look
at this as though you're you're caring
for
an adult with special needs
and that she is a danger to herself
or she just has no ability to protect
herself from danger
that's a totally different pathway
that's i'm going to seek to get control
of her finances
and i'm going to seek to get control i'm
going to pay her rent using her money
i'm going to pay her rent right
which i actually do i am in control of
her finances since the fourth marriage
okay great so she hand willingly handed
that over to me so that's a good
excellent first step um yeah the
the
i know that this community doesn't like
this phrasing is it's it's just easier
in the short term the highly functioning
autistic folks i've worked with
have been the best people to get very
very clear boundaries
if you do this i will no longer be
accessible to you you are choosing him
or you are choosing me
and that is a choice that you get to
make
and so i don't know what that boundary
looks like all i can do is look at the
last
four rounds and realize that that hasn't
worked
and so i
the other side of it is if you choose to
love your mom by walking alongside her
and protecting her
um
i would come up with some even firmer
boundaries
like
i mean
i don't really know how to do that um
i do i don't know how to do it in this
situation without sitting down with both
you and your brother and your mom um
what i mean by that is continue to
you've got money you've got hopefully
got retirement accounts hopefully you've
got bank accounts hopefully you've got
insurance stuff hopefully you're paying
the bills and so some new person doesn't
have access my fear is that some new
person is going to come give some very
compelling reasons and she's gonna
revoke that access for you
um and that then you'll end up in a mess
or you
ask for guardianship and you ask her to
sign over guardianship for you and that
may be a path forward when it comes to
really really strong boundaries or you
put her in some sort of assisted living
facility or something
ultimately
you've got to decide how you're going to
do this and when you make that decision
don't resent don't get mad at the other
side of it because both sides are a
choice either you're going to step out
and say these are my boundaries and
there's a potential mom's going to go
off the rails
and become victim to somebody who's a
predator or you're going to be all in
protecting mom
and you just know you're going to lose a
lot of weekends over it because that's a
choice that you made but once you make
that choice
be at peace with it be at peace with it
be at peace with it and i know that's
hard you have to practice being you have
to and that's when you have to sleep
take care of your body all those things
you have to eat right you're going to
have your friends you're going to do all
that stuff too that you know
but make your choice and exhale through
it and i'm sorry that you're in this i
know this sounds so hard it just sounds
hard hard hard
like i said at the beginning your mom's
super lucky to have you
make a choice to make peace with it